This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Norton Security.
you might get a surprise one as a kid or an
awful embarrassing ones as an adult.
But what the heck causes nosebleeds?
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews
60% of the population will experience epistaxis
EP EH STECK SIS or a nasal hemorrhage sometime
in their life.
They’re embarrassing, messy, and fun fact:
in Japanese pop culture a sign of sexual arousal.
So what happens when Mount Vesuvius erupts
on your face?
Well , your nose is filled with lots of blood
vessels with only a thin membrane to protect
them.
Often this membrane gets torn or irritated.
and boom, your face is dripping with blood.
there’s two kinds of nosebleeds, anterior
and posterior.
Anterior nosebleeds are in the part of your
nose called Kiesselbach's triangle and are
triggered by an irritation to the lower nasal
septum, the thin membrane that separates your
nostrils.
Kids most often get this kind.
I think they spend too much time digging for
gold.
More common in adults, posterior nosebleeds
originate further back and higher up in the
nose, to where arteries are.
Sometimes they can be severe enough to warrant
medical attention.
So how do you get them?
Well the nose is in a vulnerable place, so
a bump or a punch might do some damage.
Other than that common irritants include cold,
high altitude, dry air.
Anything that dries out your nose leaves the
lower nasal septum vulnerable.
A little scratch from a fingernail can start
the blood gushing.
Although.
spontaneous nosebleeds might be a sign of
hypertension or infection disease, or even
more rarely Vitamin C deficiency, anemia,
or heart failure.
Those are common causes, what about more strange
ones you ask?
Recently it was reported that
A scottish backpacker who had just come back
from South Asia started to have frequent nosebleeds.
After a few weeks, she went to see a doctor,
who thought it wasn’t serious and told her
just to go home.
Then one night, she felt the blood clot move.
Upon closer inspection she saw something with
ridges.
A leech had lived in her nose for FOUR WEEKS.
Another nasty nosebleed comes out of Saudi
Arabia.
A 22 year old man reportedly kept getting
nosebleeds on and off for about three years.
When he finally went to the doctor, they discovered
a tooth growing in his nasal cavity!
So how do you stop a nosebleed?
Dr. Mary Pickett, an instructor in medicine
at Harvard Medical School says a pinch will
do the trick and you should treat all nosebleeds
like an anterior one.
Pinch your nose halfway between the tip of
the nose and the bridge.
Lean forward so the blood doesn’t drip down
your throat.
Hold tight for five minutes.
If that doesn’t do the trick, repeat.
On rare occasions you might need to go to
the hospital.
More complicated methods include cauterizing
the blood vessel using silver nitrate.
Researchers from Detroit Medical Center won
an ig nobel prize in 2014 for using an old
school approach.
The award celebrates silly and surprising
but practical research.
The researchers couldn’t stop a young girl’s
nose bleed with traditional methods so they
tried salt pork.
They say that "there are some clotting factors
in the pork ... and the high level of salt
will pull in a lot of fluid from the nose”.
Unfortunately this might cause more harm than
good if its coated in bacteria so it’s not
recommended.
So do you get nosebleeds?
How do you stop them?
Would ever use pork?
Let us know in the comments below, while you’re
at it, hit that subscribe button and keep
coming back here for more Dnews every day
of the week